hello grammarians so if you've ever
written a list of items or actions you
know that we use commas to separate the
elements of that list sometimes though
our lists get a bit complicated and we
have something called a complex list and
when that's the case instead of commas
we use semicolons let's look at an
example
I've lived in quite a few places across
the country so if I want to list a few
of them I can say I've lived in New York
New York San Francisco California and
Knoxville Tennessee the items in this
list are New York New York
San Francisco California and Knoxville
Tennessee you can see that they're
separated with these semicolons
what makes this list complex is the fact
that all of the items in it have commas
in them cities and states need to be
separated with commas so if our list had
commas in it as well that would get kind
of confusing it would end up looking
like New York comma in New York comma
San Francisco comma California comma and
Knoxville comma Tennessee this has a
pretty high chance of being
misunderstood it could look like I'm
saying I've lived in New York a place
called New York San Francisco just
California in general and Knoxville
Tennessee that's just a lot of commas
and a lot of chances for
misinterpretation so this is not what we
want
another sort of complex list is when we
have a list inside of another list this
looks something like I need to buy a
textbook a workbook and a dictionary for
Spanish a calculator for math and a map
for geography because we have semicolons
here separating the elements of the list
instead of commas we can tell that the
textbook the workbook and the dictionary
are all for Spanish class to get the
same information across without using
semicolons we'd have to say something
like I need to buy a textbook for
Spanish comma a workbook for Spanish
comma a dictionary for Spanish comma a
calculator for math comma and a map for
geography that sentence is way longer
than it needs to be we can condense it
down to this much shorter sentence here
by using semicolons in the place of the
regular list commas because the
semicolon is playing such a special role
in the case of the complex list
sometimes it's referred to
as a super comma it's essentially acting
as a comma but removing some of the
confusion that might occur if we had so
many commas in one sentence that
semicolons and complex lists when we
have a list inside of another list or
elements in a list that already have
commas in them we use semicolons to
separate all the elements to make sure
the sentence is extra clear you can
learn anything
page out